former first lady barbara Bush passes
away justice Gorsuch actually rules
against President Trump and James Comey
continues to make his pathetic rounds
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so we have a lot to get to today
including stormy Daniels on the view
yesterday just a lot of news breaking
but I want to begin today by saying
thank you to our sponsors over at my
Patriot supply so here is the reality if
there is some sort of emergency if
there's an earthquake or there's a
tornado if there's some sort of natural
disaster or man-made disaster you can't
count on the government to be there in
the next five minutes you are probably
going to need some resources to sustain
you at least for a relatively short
period of time FEMA is not exactly doing
its job all over the country sometimes
they do sometimes they don't but this is
the the best thing you can do is prepare
while things are calm which is why this
is the week to stock up on emergency
food so today you can get this Ben
Shapiro special offer from my Patriot
supply right now by one four week
emergency food kit for only 198 bucks
and you get one for free so it's buy one
get one free over at emergency food kits
rather they prepare with Ben's calm
checkout prepare with Ben calm purchase
one right now my Patriot supply will
send you an additional four week food
kit for free call eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen or order online and prepare
with Ben calm these kits do include
breakfast lunches and dinners and they
are packed in a rugged slimline tote the
food lasts for 20 if they're in storage
for 25 years it is shipped for free
discreetly to your home there's a
purchase limit of two per order so now
is the time to do it supplies are
limited again eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen or prepare with
Ben comprehend calm again when you go
there check it out get your emergency
food supply you get a four week
emergency food kit for just 198 bucks
and you get another one for free and
this ensures that you and your family
are safe you stick it in the closet
don't worry about it until next time an
emergency hits and you're the person who
is prepared prepare with Ben calm that's
prepared with Ben calm okay so the big
news yesterday obviously was the death
of Barbara Bush so Barbara Bush the wife
to one president and the mother of
another passed away at age 92 and the
universal admiration for Barbara Bush
was really something nice I think in an
era where everybody seems to be at each
other's throats over politics a couple
of things are worth noting right off the
bat first of all if you look at all the
obituaries it says that Barbara Bush was
most famous obviously for as I say being
the wife of one president and the mother
of another there's this weird idea that
goes around in feminist circles that
being a wife and being a mother is
somehow degrading to women that somehow
it is it is what you do not in your
relationship
with others but what you do in your
career that matters most well for the
vast majority of human beings it is what
you do in your family life and the kind
of children that you raise that is going
to be your final legacy on the world
right Barbara Bush said this herself in
1990 she was speaking at Wellesley shoes
protested in 1990 so this just shows how
long these college protests have been
going on but Barbara Bush who was then
First Lady of the United States she
talked about why family was valuable in
life in 1990 at a graduation so I want
to offer a new legend the winner of the
hoop race will be the first to realize
her dream not society's dreams her own
personal dream
who knows somewhere out in this audience
may even be someone who will one day
follow in my footsteps and preside over
the White House as the president's
spouse and I wish him well okay so yeah
she's a person who definitely understood
the value of family one of the charming
clips that was going around yesterday as
well as a clip from 2011 George HW Bush
and Barbara were on the Today Show
together and and they read with their
granddaughter actually and george w
bush's daughter and they they read
George HW read some love letters that
he'd written to to Barbara and you can
sort of see their relationship
encapsulated in this in this short clip
on December 12 1943
my darling bar this should be a very
easy letter to write my grandparents
have been writing each other love
letters for more than 60 years I love
you precious with all my heart and to
know that you love me means my life 6
1994 for Barbara Pierce from gh WB will
you marry me oops
I forgot you did that 49 years ago today
I was very happy on that day in 1945 but
even happier today you give me joy that
few men know I've come perhaps the
highest mountain in the world but even
that cannot hold a candle to being
Barbara's husband mum used to tell me
now George don't walk ahead you never
listen to your mother
little did I know I was only trying to
keep up keep up a bar bar Pierce Vermont
and August Street in Rye New York
Speaker of the House okay so in Barbara
Bush issue she was definitely a pistol
there's a good piece in the New York
Times by Christopher Buckley who is a a
novelist and speech writer for VP HW
from 81 to 83 then he talks about
exactly who Barbara Bush was he said
that he learned a couple of lessons from
her he said there was no falsity no
pretence no guile most spin no art to
Barbara Bush who died on Tuesday
she was what-you-see-is-what-you-get I'm
on about the letter Americans are always
clamoring about the virtues of
transparency Barbara Bush was as
transparent as distilled water whoo but
she would have said of her own adored
son as he weighed a campaign for the
presidency if we can't find more than
two or three families to run for high
office that's silly there are a lot of
great families there are other people
out there that are very qualified we've
had enough bushes thanks MA if she was
mrs. no-nonsense she also had a playful
even girlish side to her on one occasion
I was alone in a freight elevator with
mr. and mrs. Bush and their Secret
Service detail when it got stuck between
floors stuck elevators are viewed grimly
by the Secret Service the atmosphere
quickly elevated to condition dread with
hands reaching for the holstered Glock
nines
orders Brockton to wrist mics and all
the rest the bushes were blithe I was
standing behind them mr. Bush's fingers
reached for mrs. Bush's derriere and
gave it a pinch she turned to him in
grin like an 18 year old hiya fella she
said so I can claim to have witnessed a
primal scene between mom and dad Bush so
just you know she was apparently a
really a really good woman by virtually
all accounts and there were tributes
that came in from the Clintons there are
tributes that came in from the Obamas in
class all across the aisle except of
course for the far left the far left
found an excuse to be upset about
Barbara Bush so Randy gerar who is a
professor at Fresno State and obviously
a delightful human being she tweeted out
Barbara Bush was a generous and smart
and amazing racist who along with her
husband raised a war criminal F out of
here with your nice words so you can
always count on Twitter to provide you
some of the best in American life but
this does demonstrate that there is a
primal hatred that exists on both sides
of the aisle unfortunately with regard
to some of these figures because the
reality is that if people can't get
beyond their own politics to to see the
personal side of people like Barbara
Bush it was not a political figure right
I mean Barbara Bush is the kind of woman
who when she was the the first lady in
1989 it was right after the election
there was a lot of talk about how babies
with AIDS if people were afraid that if
they held the baby with AIDS or if they
if a baby they'd spit up on them that
they would actually get AIDS
Barbara Bush and went to a Children's
Center where there were babies with AIDS
and she went she picked him up she
carried them around in front of the
cameras just to demonstrate that this
was not a serious danger and yet the the
fact that people hate each other so much
in today's modern politics they're
ripping on Barbara Bush 92 years old on
the day of her death he's really classy
it's not quite the same thing as ripping
on Ted Kennedy the day
his death I mean that guy actually left
a woman to drown in a car Barbara Bush
did nothing of the kind but you know dad
that may be the extent to which our
politics have gone awry now speaking of
our politics and going awry the the
story of the day yesterday continued to
be the storm easy annuals fall out the
Michael Cohen
fall out and all of it continues to be
very weird and very bizarre we're
obviously living in a reality show
simulation the the the former leading
presidential candidate for the Democrats
for a certain period of time Bernie
Sanders actually tweeted out today that
he wants cardi B to decide Social
Security Policy C I was joking when I
said I thought the cardi B's tax policy
was great cuz I don't think cardi B
knows all that much about tax policy
Bernie Sanders apparently was not joking
that just shows you how crazy things
have gotten
well now stormy Daniels was appearing on
the view and if you don't believe that
so much of our controversy so much of
the hatred that we see in America's
public life is now driven by the TV
theatrics of our political actors all
you have to do is watch TV for five
minutes and be disabused of this so
stormy Daniels who is a self
aggrandizing porn star who had sex with
a married man in 2006 earned one hundred
and thirty thousand dollars out of it
right before the election and then
decided to forego the one hundred and
thirty thousand dollars she's giving it
to Planned Parenthood which is obviously
a very classy move and she instead wants
to make a fortune by speaking openly
about her affair with Donald Trump which
lasted apparently a grand total of one
night and now she's on the view and on
the view she's explaining that she is
not in it for the money
that she's not in it for the glory she
is obviously in it for both the money
and the glory and listen she's a free
person in the United States she can do
whatever she pleases but that doesn't
mean that we have to put aside our
critical thinking skills she showed up
with her lawyer Michael a vanetti at the
Michael Kohn hearing the other day in
New York there was no reason for her to
be there she showed up there because she
wants to stay in the news and she's very
good at staying in the news and the news
are very good about keeping her in the
news so here it was Michael a vanetti
explaining that this was not a publicity
stunt in stormy Daniels saying this was
not a publicity stunt to show up in
court to an event that had nothing to do
with her I want to address the first
part I'm gonna let her address the
second part as it relates to us having
nothing to do with the case I mean
that's just not accurate on Friday judge
wood who I know granted me access to
that case stated that she would hear
from me as to any issue that I wanted to
speak about
recognising that we did have standing in
connection with that case because some
of these documents that were seized
relate to her and in fact the warrants
stemmed in significant part from what
happened to my client so we had every
right to be there in judge would the
city and federal judge would not have
granted me access to address the court
if we had no business being there but
I'm gonna let stormy speak to this issue
of making money from the tour etc guys
can I just say first of all I did not
name the tour that you won't hear me say
it I haven't promoted that name I think
it's awful and I think the name is awful
yeah I don't like to use I think it's
cheesy and a play on someone else's idea
and I try not to do that a strip club
owner and the Carolinas came up with it
and everyone else has latched on to it
as far as the tour I've yes I've gotten
more bookings than usual but I'm doing
the job that I've been doing for the
last almost 20 years yes there's a lot
of publicity but I didn't do it for that
because this isn't what I want to be
known for as a matter of fact I hid for
quite a while and it's it's overwhelming
and intimidating okay I'm sorry I'm
sorry that like I'm sorry the the media
portraying stormy Daniels has some sort
of great heroine who's coming out here
because she just wants the truth told
this isn't what she wants to be known
for yes I'm sure she wants to be known
for the witches of breastwork that's
what she wants to be known for anyway
she really wants to be known for is
stripping but not on the make America
horny again tour which is what the name
of her tour is that's the name that she
doesn't want to mention there and she
she feels really bad about that because
I mean that's humiliating it's not
humiliating to strip naked in front of a
bunch of men after talking about having
affair with the President of the United
States that's not humiliating it's
really the name of the tour that's
really where you got a drug line I mean
if you're gonna talk about class that's
really where you gotta draw the line
it's not you know the being a
pornographic actress thing that's that's
humiliating in any way it really is the
fact that you're now speaking on the
view fully dressed about all this stuff
that's that's not what you were on and
be remembered for you definitely want to
be remembered for those lesbian those
lesbian porn scenes that's that's
definitely the thing that's gonna go on
the epitaph right there like what in the
world and we're supposed to believe that
our politics are not broken in any
significant way I'm gonna show you more
of our politics being broken in just a
second because this is this interview on
the view really was quite astonishing
but first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over $1 shave club so
dudes your bathroom called and it is
time to give it the cleaning it deserves
get rid of all the junk that's lying
around I know in my bathroom there was a
lot of junk just lying around stuff he'd
gotten from the drugstore and that you
can throw out now because everything you
need is coming in a small box from
Dollar Shave Club dollarshaveclub.com
delivers everything you need to look
feel and smell your best they're more
than just razors and it's better than
shopping in a store they have razors
shave butter shampoo body wash
toothpaste everything you need to look
smell and feel your best I get an
amazing high-quality shave every morning
for my Dollar Shave Club executive razor
right here under my drawn line it is the
best razor that I have used and they
have their dr. Carver's shea butter
which is also fantastic it goes on clear
so you don't cut your jugular when
you're shaving and since DSC delivers
everything directly to you you don't
have to set foot in a store wandering
the aisles hunting for razors shampoo
body wash toothpaste none of that clean
up your bathroom the end of morning
routine join Dollar Shave Club today and
just for just 5 bucks with Free Shipping
you'll get the 6 blade executive razor
plus trial sizes of shave butter body
cleanser and the one wipe Charlies then
keep the blades coming for a few bucks
more every month get yours as
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben for the
special deal dollarshaveclub.com slash
Ben check it out there's a reason
they're one of the fastest growing
companies in the country
ok so speaking of the craziness of
stormy Daniels on the view everybody's
favorite portion of television of course
yesterday was the reality TV show reveal
of the of the likeness of the person who
allegedly threatened stormy Daniel so I
do love that storm and Daniel says in
this interview she tried to stay silent
about this for a long time well no
actually she tried to sell the story to
In Touch magazine and then she tried to
sell the story to National Enquirer and
then she stole that sold the story to
Trump and now she's selling the story to
the media so that's not good at being
quiet about things just last I checked
but she says in 2011 after In Touch
Weekly was going to print a story about
her having a one-night affair with Trump
and she was gonna get like 15 grand for
all of that then some weird guy came up
to her in the parking lot of some
grocery store with her daughter and said
to her something about how this is how a
nice baby you got there would be a shame
if something happened to her mother
which is just something from a bad dime
novel maybe it happened maybe it didn't
but this reveal on the view is just so
ridiculous I'm sorry if this were if
this was something that really mattered
to stormy Daniels I assumed she would
make a police report of some sort I
assumed that she would actually turn in
this photograph to the police I assume
that she had taken a little more
seriously than to go on the view right
to reveal it
listen I'm not ripping on the view I
desperately want to appear on the view
but that said this does not exactly pass
the smell test in terms of non
publicity-seeking behavior from stormy
Daniels you recently sat down with the
forensic artists a very well-known one
who created a sketch of the alleged
suspect based on your memory from that
day and now you're ready to reveal that
sketch for the first time can we take a
look at that with you and to your
recollection is is that the person that
threatened you absolutely looks exactly
like that person Wow
to your recollection is it the most
generic looking photograph you have ever
seen of any human being ever it looks
like every male star of last 30 years in
Hollywood Wow
thanks thanks stormy for that you've
really cleared it up I'm sure that all
the information will certainly be look
forthcoming although I have my own
suspicions that it was Tom Brady fresh
off the flight gate he had to do
something to get his name out of the
headlines and so he decided to go and
threaten stormy Daniels in 2011 wearing
the boy band haircut just really strong
stuff from stormy Daniels there and the
media taking all this stuff seriously is
truly incredible but of course that's
not the only stuff they're taking very
very seriously they are also taking very
seriously and continuing to do so all of
the all of the information about Michael
Cohen so Michael Cohen of course is
president Trump's lawyer and Michael
Cohen was dragged into court by washing
he dragged the FBI into court because he
is suing for access to all the materials
that they seized from his offices
there's a lot of speculation about what
exactly is in those materials what
exactly Michael Cohen has to worry about
but the two big headlines to come out of
this are that Michael Cohen is in
serious legal jeopardy which could be
trouble for Trump and too then one of
Michael cones clients was of course the
the talk show host on Fox News Sean
Hannity right who with whom I'm friendly
so Michael a vanetti who's the lawyer
for stormy Daniels again on the view he
says that he has a no fear that Michael
Cohen will eventually flip on Trump and
Trump will be taken down by the great
and brave stormy Daniels here is
actually I notice I'm we see a vanetti
saga mean the guy just must have he must
live at these TV studios as often as
he's appearing on TV you think Michael
Cohen's wife is going to advise him to
take a twenty-year bullet for the
president what about no matter what
about his children I mean listen Donny
Deutsch knows Michael Cohen and
we know other people that know Michael
Cohen he loves his kids he loves his
family and he loves his kids more than
he loves Donald Trump I understand the
loyalty and all that other stuff that
only goes so if it goes so far when your
own children are saying dad what's going
on it's either Trump or not what your
kids grow up the level of speculation
that is occurring right now on cable
television is just astonishing I was
watching CNN again at the gym yesterday
and I don't remember whose show it was
but one of the shows was just the entire
hour was dedicated to speculation about
the connection between michael cohen and
sean hannity which is cable news the
other favorite topic they're fascinated
with the idea that sean hannity had the
same lawyer as the president well is
that really a giant shock that sean
hannity is friendly with the lawyer for
the president sean hannity is probably
calling trump every night in fact I have
pretty good information that he does
talk to President Trump on a very
frequent basis The Washington Post
reported the same thing today that's not
any sort of surprise and he's known
Michael Cohen for years the only weird
legal issue here is that sean has
alternatively claims that Cohen was his
lawyer that Cohen was not his lawyer for
purposes of confidentiality and
privilege that does make some difference
but the nusers that are going crazy over
this the the cnn's and MSNBC's that are
going totally nuts over this i'm just
wondering what's so crazy about hannity
having the same lawyer as trump like i
assume that hillary clinton's lawyers
represent a lot of members of media
because she probably is represented by
mainstream law firms is that the end of
the world right half the people in the
media worked in the Clinton
administration is that supposed to be
some sort of great shock to anyone okay
for example you seem Chuck Todd over at
Emma's over at NBC and MSNBC saying that
he is stunned by Fox News's coverage of
the fact that Sean Hannity was using
Michael Cohen as his lawyer and covering
the Michael Cohn's
fallout at the same time I'm just I am
stunned that Fox had no punitive
response not a sean hannity must
disclose every night not a he can't
cover this story not a he's been
suspended for a week nothing not a
single thing they are saying this is
okay for anybody that works at Fox News
okay literally George Stephanopoulos the
chief of staff for Hillary Clinton who
wrote in his memoirs about crime with
Hillary Clinton after President Clinton
- interviewed Hillary Clinton multiple
times during the last campaign and ABC
News made no disclosure about that at
the top of any of the shows and he
covered it as an objective journalist
how was he magically changed into an
objective journalist the answer as he
wasn't it's just that the media don't
care when it's a lefty who has close
associations with members of the
Democratic Party they cave her a deeply
when a member of the media has close
relationships with top members of the
Republican Party right brian Stelter
said some of the same stuff on on CNN he
said if Rachel Maddow had been getting
legal advice from Hillary's attorney
Sean Hannity would go crazy let's let's
imagine a parallel universe where
Hillary Clinton's president Rachel
Maddow was discovered to have been
gained secret legal advice from a
Clinton lawyer never mind
the idea that that Clinton lawyer would
have been raided and we'd been under
investigation
if Maddow was under the microscope like
that Hannity would be he would be
ripping he would be going wild with it
he would be talking about it non-stop
and I think what it's so frustrating to
most Americans when these partisan Wars
is the lack of consistency that Hannity
would would erupt if it were the other
side so I agree on the lack of
consistency point my only question is
why is that the brian Stelter is willing
to ignore the lack of consistency on his
own side of the aisle I like Brian but
I'm just wondering why is it that all
these people on the left side of the
aisle are willing to completely overlook
the fact that half of the media are
staffed by people who I'm sure Cheryl
lawyers with Hillary Clinton and we're
probably interviewing her at the same
time they don't seem to care about any
of that right mean the head of CBS News
was the brother of Ben Rhodes whose than
it was the National Security Adviser
under President Obama you know whether
or not that makes a difference in news
coverage is is questionable but it is
something that ought to be displayed on
a regular basis these close
relationships that are happening the
media all the time I'm just amazed that
the media suddenly latch on to all of
this except they're not really amazed
they don't like Sean Hannity very much
and obviously they don't they don't like
President Trump very much now speaking
of not liking president Trump James
Comey continues to do his tour of his
publicity tour about his book
demonstrating a higher loyalty to a
higher royalty attitude is very
interested in making a lot of money off
of his book and he is non-stop on
television lately
it is really amusing to watch him so
yesterday he said that President Trump
has a weird obsession with James Comey
there's what Comey said he said Donald
Trump is treating me like a scorned high
school date dude you're the one who
literally went and wrote a book about
how much you don't like Trump my Trump
wasn't saying
a lot of stuff about you until you
decide to come back with the book now
I'm not really pleased with how Trump
has handled the whole James Comey
debacle I didn't think that it was
greatly handled in the first place but
for James Comey to be walking around
saying that Donald Trump is the scorned
lover in this particular relationship
seems to be ignorant of things like
mirrors and self-awareness it's it's
pretty incredible
and speaking of lack of self-awareness
watch as Eric Holder tries to defend
James Comey from the predations of
Donald Trump he says the Donald Trump
does not believe in the rule of law
remember this is the Attorney General
who was held in in contempt of Congress
for failing to turn over record this is
the guy who was responsible for the Fast
& Furious scandal this is the guy who
described himself as the President of
the United States his wingman as opposed
to you know a law enforcement officer
the chief law enforcement officer of the
country and he's he's complaining about
Donald Trump not believing in the rule
of law and the media are just sitting
there taking this and then people wonder
why people are not taking the media
seriously this is why right here how do
you make sense of those two different
ways the president talks about law and
order well he believes the situational
law and order and there is no way that I
think you can resolve the tension that
you have just described he is not a
believer in a base in the rule of law he
wants to make sure that those people who
he likes the people who support him are
treated in one way and those other
people whoever those other people are
are treated in a different way okay so I
love it that that Eric Holder is sitting
here saying this with a straight face
that Donald Trump you know he wants to
make sure that only his allies are
treated fairly but everybody else is
treated unfairly
you were the Attorney General under
President Obama who utilized the IRS or
at least his IRS went after a
conservative nonprofit you were the
Attorney General during fast and furious
you were the Attorney General during the
HHS scandal there are a dozen scandals
had happened under Eric Holder and Eric
Holder was simultaneously describing
himself as Barack Obama's wingman and
now he says that Donald Trump is
inconsistent about the use of law
enforcement it's really incredible
speaking of inconsistent about the use
of law enforcement James Comey you know
again the guy with the higher loyalty he
comes out and he says that he has no
opinion on disciplining andrew mckay the
undermine him of course is deputy
director of the FBI when James Comey was
there and now turns out that Andrew
McCabe repeatedly lied to the FBI he
repeatedly lied over and over
and that's why he was fired and now
James Comey says well I have no opinion
on prosecuting Andrew McCabe I really
have nothing to say about that so he
didn't deserve the discipline he got
Andrew McCabe no I think the process I
don't have a view on what the ultimate
discipline should have been but this is
the system working this is the Justice
Department holding accountable its
employees to the truth so he has no
opinion on what should happen to Andrew
McCabe amazing can't depending on what
should happen to Hillary Clinton
he has opinions on what should happen to
president Trump but he has no opinion on
what should happen to enter mckay but
the guy who worked underneath him and
who was simultaneously leaking materials
to the media and pretending that
somebody else inside via the inside the
FBI was put was performing those leaks
the Inspector General has a full report
on Andrew McCabe okay and what they
found is that McCabe lacked candor on
multiple occasions and violated FBI
policy when you authorize the disclosure
of sensitive investigative information
to a reporter and James Comey has no
opinion on any of this but don't worry
the only people who are engaging in
selective use of law enforcement our
members of the Trump administration and
look how the media prop call me up right
Stephen Colbert has on James Comey last
night Comey actually raised Colbert's
ratings which is not a shock because
Colbert's ratings have been very up and
down and they drank together in come--it
and Colbert because there was that story
in commis book about how Comey after
being fired drank red wine from a from a
paper cup on a plane on the way home to
Washington DC so of course Colbert and
call me drank together the last time
Colbert drank with somebody was Hillary
Clinton not a shock there either but
here is Colbert really just massaging
massaging Comey shoulders if it felt
like you were working for a mob boss
were you surprised that you got whacked
because that's what they knew I actually
was quite surprised because I thought
I'm leading the Russia investigation
even though our relationship was
becoming strained there's no way I'm
gonna get fired or whacked because why
why wouldn't you get fired because that
would be a crazy thing to do why would
you fire the FBI director who's leading
the Russia investigation because you're
leading the Russia investigation what it
says I don't know if you've dealt with
mob bosses before but they don't like to
be investigated okay so Stephen Colbert
of course is making a point that he
doesn't know that he's making which is
if James Comey really thought all these
terrible things about Trump why didn't
he quit the first day why'd you just
quit and say the president asked me for
a loyalty oath I wasn't willing to give
him a loyalty oath and I'm not gonna
serve under to that president but of
course James Comey is there in his in
his I don't even know it he's wearing I
mean he's wearing like a black shirt and
a grey jacket that makes him look like
something straight out of 50s lounge and
Stephen Colbert is is talking with him
of course in the most glowing terms
about President Trump all of this stuff
is so off-putting James Comey has
nothing new to tell we know his story
okay and his story is what his story is
he's so self aggrandizing they I think
he's actually undercutting his own cause
James call me again former FBI director
yesterday he said that he imitated
LeBron James on leadership no this isn't
this isn't a real this is just
astonishing this isn't him pandering in
any way this is what he says I'm sure
that he just goes around talking about
LeBron James on leadership this is what
James Comey does admire LeBron James and
he's probably about to find out I used
to talk about him all over the FBI and
say he illustrates what the endless
pursuit of excellence looks like but
every offseason I've read he tries to
find a part of his game to make better
which is crazy because he's already
better than everybody else it's because
he measures himself not against the
others but against himself so I used to
say inside the FBI look this is a great
organization but it's not good enough it
can't ever be good enough we have to
find parts of our game to make better
look at LeBron James he is in sufferable
I'm sorry he's just insufferable there's
no English James Comey and not think
that he's actually doing damage to the
anti-trump cause by being this
insufferably douche I mean it's just
awful that's not a word but I've coined
it for James Comey my goodness gracious
you know the president Trump doesn't
help himself by the way when he fires
back on this he should just let James
Komi hang out there in the breeze I mean
he really should just let james comey
i'll six foot nine of him say silly
things and be looked at is silly but
president Trump can't help himself so he
tweets out slippery James call me the
worst FBI director in history was not
fired because of the phony Russia
investigation where by the way there was
no collusion except by the Thames you
know mr. president you literally said on
national television to Lester Holt that
you fired him because of the Russia
investigation like you literally said
that that's the only reason there's a
special counsel right now
hey the revisionist history from
President Trump is not helpful here so
James Comey may be a terrible FBI
director I think that he was James Comey
maybe a self aggrandizing douche I think
that he is but president Trump made a
big mistake when he fired James Comey
and then went on national television to
brag about it saying that the real
reason he fired James Comey is cuz Comey
wouldn't come out and say that he was
innocent in the Russia investigation
that forced Rod Rosenstein the guy who
wrote the letter and that provided the
impetus for firing James Comey that
force Rosenstein to recuse himself an
appoint Robert Muller there would be no
Robert Muller today if it were not for
President Trump firing James Comey and
then talking about it on national
television to him denying it now is just
silly you know again the president
should be above these things he should
just let it all play out everyone can
see this stuff okay I have enough faith
in the American people that they can
look at the Stormy's annual stuff and
they can look at her reviewing
ridiculous mock-ups of generic-looking
white men who threatened her in a
parking lot and say all of this seems
like reality TV show nonsense the
president apparently doesn't have that
faith or he can't control himself so he
tweeted out about stormy Daniels he said
that this was a con job as well he said
quote a sketch years later about a
non-existent man a total con job playing
the fake news media for fools but they
know it exclamation point again you know
for fake news media for fools all of
that is capitalized which is weird but
you know why is the president doing this
I don't think it serves his purpose I
think that not only does it not serve
his purpose it's counterproductive and
in a very serious way because what he
really should be he shouldn't be saying
anything but if his people are saying
anything it should be well if that
actually happened then the president had
no knowledge of any of that when he just
says that this is a non-existent man
when he comes out and says this this
never happened now he's in a food fight
with a former porn star he had sex with
and none of this is good for the
president none of this is good for the
President's agenda now speaking of not
great for the President's agenda
yesterday there were a couple of dings
in in the White House
those things came courtesy of Justice
Gorsuch so there's been a lot of talk of
course about justice Gorsuch and justice
course which being president Trump's
main main victory as presidents of the
United States there's a lot of truth to
that I think justice Gorsuch has been
terrific thus far well he ruled on a
case yesterday and a lot of folks were
very angry at him they were angry at him
because he sided with the courts
liberals on a case with regard to the
mandatory deportation of Alita of
illegal immigrants so the case was
called sessions versus de Maya and
involved a legal immigrant who came to
the United States years ago as an adult
this guy was twice convicted of burglary
federal law permits deportation of legal
immigrants if they are convicted of an
aggravated felony one type of which is a
crime of violence the Obama and Trump
administrations both claimed is
according to allah pundit over at hot
air that burglary can be categorized as
a crime of violence because of the way
the statute is worded any crime which by
its nature involves a substantial risk
that physical force against the person
or property of another may be used in
the course of committing the offense is
a crime of violence whether or not
physical force was actually used in
deciding whether a crime by its nature
as a crime of violence courts are
supposed to look at what the ordinary
case involving that crime might look
like so the courts for liberals thought
that this was unconstitutionally vague
this did not make clear when you could
support somebody and when you could not
deport somebody and Gorsuch concurred he
said that the Congress has to do a
better job of writing its legislation
right here's what he wrote he wrote
vague laws invite arbitrary power before
the Revolution the crime of treason and
English law was so capacious ly
construed that the mere expression of
disfavored opinions could invite
transportation or death
the founders cited the Crown's abuse
have pretended crimes like this as one
of their reasons for revolution today's
vague laws may not be as invidious but
they can't invite the exercise of
arbitrary power all the same by leaving
the people in the dark about what the
law demands and allowing prosecutors and
courts to make it up so this does not
sound like a wildly liberal decision
from Justice Gorsuch in fact it sounds
very much like what Justice Scalia might
have said in the same case there's an
argument over whether this statute was
vague or whether the statute was not
vague and nowhere does it say the
Congress can't simply redraw the statute
to make it less vague and then apply it
going forward again there was a case
called United States versus Johnson a
couple of years ago about the armed
career criminal act and it said if you
were convicted of three prior violent
felonies under the law then you could be
a given extra prison time and there was
some wiggle room in what it meant to be
a violent felon and Antonin Scalia
actually
wrote with the four liberals as well as
John Roberts they wrote the majority
opinion so it's not you know out of the
realm of possibility for Justice Gorsuch
to and people are saying well this means
he's Anthony Kennedy that's not true I
just don't I just don't think that's
right at all I think justice course
which continues to be a real asset to
the court and I think the ruling
yesterday it's controversial but I don't
think that ed Gorsuch gets this one
wildly wrong now speaking of
controversies that may mean more inside
the administration apparently nikki
Haley is now in a fight with other
members of the administration so nikki
Haley who is of course at the United
Nations as I have said my spirit animal
nikki Haley at the United Nations is my
favorite thing in American government in
a very long time
she's the US ambassador to the UN well
I'm on Sunday she said that there would
be new sanctions against Russia that
were forthcoming and then the
administration walked that back and
Larry Kudlow suggested that she had been
confused and so nikki Haley let Dana
Perino know in a statement over Fox News
quote with all due respect I don't get
confused knows after Kudlow had told the
reporters that there might have been
some confusion momentary confusion he
said she was certainly not confused come
back down I was wrong to say that
totally wrong so apparently what
happened is that she made these comments
and then the circumstances sort of
changed and she was not informed of that
and so there's a miscommunication in the
White House that is not a particular
shot but Haley getting very aggressive
about the fact that she was not confused
about anything I think that's because
you know look Nikki and there's some
pretty strong principles and I think
that she's right to hold those
principles now one thing you got to be
aware of is there are members of the
White House you don't like nikki Haley
and there are members of the White House
who are not fond of Mike Mike Pence the
Vice President so there's a story from
the New York Times today all about how
nikki Haley and Mike Pence are secretly
planning a coup inside the White House
the Mike Pence wants to run for
president and nikki Haley would run for
VP in 2020 if something should happen to
President Trump but they're sort of
stationing themselves that way this of
course would lead to president Trump
being suspicious and angry just this
week President Trump knocked down a
person who's supposed to be appointed a
national security adviser for pence who
was coming from Nikki Haley's team the
reason for that is that this particular
person apparently was not a trump
supporter and Trump has a nose for such
things he doesn't want anybody who
didn't support him in the last election
cycle being in any position remotely
approaching power well with all of that
said you know the the the idea that Mike
Pence and nikki Haley are planning some
sort of coup inside the
I don't see the evidence for that I
think that a lot there's a lot of bad
blood inside the white house
unfortunately and that bad blood inside
the white house has not died down over
the period of time that the president
has been president in fact in some ways
it's gotten worse but the media also
have an interest in fostering this sort
of chaos they're very much interested in
continuing to push the notion that the
white house is a place of backstabbing
and backbiting in which the vice
president is going to go up against the
President and all that sort of nonsense
I just don't I don't buy it I know all
these people who are who are now talking
about and I don't think that this is a
real thing okay in just a second I want
to talk about what's happening in
California where freedom of speech is
really on the line it makes a big
difference to folks like me who engage
in freedom of speech for living here in
California on a regular basis but first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire.com and subscribe for $9.99 a month
you get a subscription to Daley why I
mean you get the rest of our show live
the rest of Andrew Clayton's show live
the rest of Michael Noel's is show live
it means that you also get to be part of
the mailbag which will be doing on
Friday this week that means that you get
to ask questions live in the mailbag I
will answer them live or you can send in
questions and we'll answer them for you
if you want the annual subscription you
can get it with 99 bucks a year you get
this to the leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler which of course is the most
magnificent of all beverage vessels if
you want to listen later for free iTunes
YouTube please subscribe it please leave
us a review we always appreciate where
the largest fastest core and
conservative podcast in the nation
all righty so meanwhile over in
California the California Legislature is
pushing a new law that really should
scare people
it essentially bans the sale of
particular books I am not kidding this
is something that is happening in the
state of California so according to
David French over at National Review
Assembly Bill 2943 would make an
unlawful business practice to engage in
a transaction intended to result or that
results in the sale or lease of goods or
services to any consumer that advertised
offer to engage in or do engage in
sexual orientation change efforts with
an individual the bill then defined
sexual orientations change efforts as
any practice that seeks to change an
individual's sexual orientation this
includes efforts to change behaviors or
gender expressions or to eliminate or
reduce sexual or romantic attractions or
feelings toward individuals of the same
sex
hey this is insane I'm sorry this is
this is insane this bill is totally
crazy it doesn't matter whether you
believe that conversion therapy works I
think the evidence on that is at best
mixed and leaning very strongly toward
no but that does not mean that you
shouldn't be able to read a book about
how to fight particular urges or that
urge you to behave in certain ways
rather the entire religious worldview is
that you have lots of urges right we all
have lots of urges and a lot of those
urges are bad for you and you should
resist those urges as much as possible
but under California law such books
could be banned in the state of
California like really and even worse it
says it includes efforts to change
behaviors or gender expressions so in
other words if I have a 3 year old kid
and that 3 year old kid is expressing
that they want to be the opposite sex I
can't take that kid to a therapist who's
going to say that who's going to try to
make sure that my kids feelings of
gender disorientation are alleviated I
don't have the ability to do that in the
state of California how in the world is
that constitutional the answer is it's
not constitutional the answer is also
that folks on the left in California
don't care so we talk about tyranny
coming in the guise of a happy face well
this is what we're talking about the
folks on the left in California
suggesting of course that gender
expression is innately baked into the
cake that you know that sexual
orientation is innately baked into the
cake and that any attempt by anyone to
say any difference should be illegal in
the state of California is fully crazy
and fully violative of First Amendment
basic freedoms it's also not true ok
it's also not true human behavior
changes on a regular basis now I'm not
talking about your desires your desires
may not be changeable but it is a fact
that when it comes to for example gender
expression 80 percent of all kids who
identify as cross gender when they are
young grow out of it by the time they
are teenagers and you're now telling me
that I have to reinforce that at the
state level and that if I don't the
state is going to sue me the state is
going to punish me but remember this
isn't just seeking the services of a
second of a psychiatrist this is if I
even buy a book about this if Barnes &
Noble carries a book about how to deal
with a child who's suffering from gender
dysphoria and that book suggests that
you don't have hormone treatment or
humor at that this may actually be a
violation of California state law I mean
this is insane
this is it's totally crazy as David
French writes to take one example large
numbers of children who exhibit gender
dysphoria eventually desist their
dysphoria resolves itself as they grow
older indeed they're serious research
indicating this is the most likely
outcome for a child with gender
dysphoria but under a B 2943 the very
act of communicating this truthful and
indeed hopeful message could very well
lead to legal jeopardy not just that you
can see a world in which California goes
even further than this and starts taking
children out of homes if you're a parent
who says listen my little girl is not a
little boy no matter what she says then
you could see the state saying you are
now in engaging in child endangerment I
cannot imagine the Supreme Court of the
United States would uphold this law I
just can't imagine it now maybe you know
maybe a couple of the justices will try
to uphold the law some of the more
radical justices but I just can't
imagine that the Supreme Court would say
this doesn't violate the First Amendment
it very very obviously violates the
First Amendment has already passed
through two committees by eight to two
and eight to one margins it may come up
for an assembly vote this week and of
course this is the future of gay
Californians the future of the left so
if you want to write folks on the right
are so unwilling to make bargains with
folks on the left about social issues
this is the reason because social
leftists are interested in not only
changing minds but enforcing that change
on people from above using the power of
government I mean this is truly evil
stuff suggesting to people they
shouldn't be able to buy books they want
to by suggesting to people that they
shouldn't be able to bring kids to the
therapist they want to bring kids to is
just insane and evil it really is and
the fact that California is pursuing it
demonstrates how crazy
the left has gone on social issues
particularly okay time for some things
that I like and then some things that I
hate so things that I like today so I'm
in the middle of reading a book by Todd
s Purdum called something wonderful and
it really is a great book it's all about
Rogers and Rogers and Hammerstein of
course I'm a huge Rodgers and
Hammerstein fan carousel Oklahoma South
Pacific The Sound of Music
the King and I they wrote a bevy of
fantastic fantastic musicals the one
I've lately been listening to a lot is
carousel and you know I have to say my
kids have totally ruined me I used to be
able to listen to carousel without
crying or without being emotional in any
way and that was the way I preferred my
life and now I listen to carousel and
and I'm a mess so well done children
you've destroyed me as a human being but
the the relationship between Rogers and
Hammerstein not only does it say
something about you know how great art
is created but the art that they created
is quintessentially American if you look
at the work that they did so much of it
is about this sort of liberal consensus
post-world War two and even during World
War two about what it was that America
stood for what America was fighting for
they have several shows about cross
cultural exchanges they have a couple of
shows specifically about fighting racism
South Pacific particularly is a very
anti-racist show they take on some
really difficult issues in carousel for
example Billy Bigelow who's the hero of
the show he's really not the hero of the
show he's the antihero of the show he's
a really bad guy I'm one of the
descriptions about Billy Bigelow his
character that I think resonates is that
Billy Bigelow and carousel is supposed
to be a really bad person who you
significantly dislike until he starts to
sing because when he's saying suddenly
he's expressing what he feels as opposed
to how he behaves and you sort of
understand all the challenges that he
faces as a character but they're spousal
abuse in carousel and it's taken very
seriously in the show it's it's just
there has been no better lyricist than
then Oscar Hammerstein despite all the
talk about how naive his lyrics are you
cannot listen to the soliloquy from
carousel without understanding how good
his understanding of human character was
and also the understanding of what male
and female are like and I think that if
you look back to - his lyrics
particularly about how women sing about
men how men sing about women and it's
very true to what men and women are on a
general level of course general level
doesn't apply to each individual but it
does apply in general and in the
soliloquy
particularly like there's one beautiful
move that oscar hammerstein makes in the
soliloquy from carousel you should go
listen to it if you haven't there's
Billy Bigelow is realizing that his wife
has told him she's pregnant and he is a
complete narrative well he's a loser
he's a bum but he thinks of himself very
highly he thinks that he's the strongest
guy in the world and so he starts off
thinking wow I could have a boy and so
he starts off talking about his boy bill
and what his boy bills gonna be like
he's gonna be as tall and as strong as a
tree you know he's gonna he's probably
gonna go around telling all the other
kids follow all the other kids that I
can lick their fathers well I can write
you know I'm a tough rough guy and my
kid's gonna be tough and rough just like
me and then he realizes halfway through
the soliloquy that this could be a girl
and then his expression totally changes
right everything changes suddenly he
realizes he has to be responsible human
being suddenly he realizes that he has
to go out and make some money
he says that you can you can have fun
with the son but you have to be a father
to a girl and by the end of the show by
the end of the song he starts off
talking about how strong he is and how
tough he is
and how he wants to see that in his son
and by the end of the song he says you
know I I can't I need to go out I need
to earn I need to go make some money
because I don't want my daughter growing
up in an area with a bunch of bums just
like me suddenly there's actually some
introspection that takes place when you
have kids that you're responsible for
it's an amazing amazing song but that's
true of all of their lyrics the
simplicity of Hammerstein s lyrics are
deceptive because people think that
great lyrics are really complex they
think that lin-manuel Miranda's lyrics
are are of the same level as Hammerstein
s or even Sondheim sort of the same
level as Hammerstein I really don't
think that's the case I think that
Hammerstein had a unique understanding
of human individuality and that's why
you can listen to lyrics from two
different characters in Hammerstein show
and they sound very different whereas
you listen to Sondheim lyrics for most
of his characters they sound like
Sondheim almost in the way the Aaron
Sorkin is a very good writer but all his
characters sound like versions of Aaron
Sorkin the same is not true for
Hammerstein okay so check out the book
something wonderful by Todd Purdum other
things that I like so it was pretty
amazing a heroic female pilot did save
the Southwest flight this is a
frightening story so obviously if you
saw yesterday it was all over the news
there was a Southwest flight from New
York to Dallas and the Southwest flight
an engine came off the plane and like
exploded part of the left engine ripped
off and part of it flew through the
window it killed a woman there was a
woman who sucked a flow out of the plane
she ended up dying
she apparently was a tremendous person
as well from from all accounts but the
woman who saved the flight with the
pilot was Tammy Joe Schultz 56 she was
one of the first Air Force pilots in the
United States to be a woman and she's a
religious Christian and apparently a
passenger on the flight said we were
leaving LaGuardia heading to Dallas we
were west of Philadelphia probably about
30,000 feet all of a sudden we heard
this loud bang rattling and then it felt
like one of the engines went out the
oxygen masks dropped and flight
attendants did a good job the pilot came
on said we're diverting to Philadelphia
and you know there was a serious medical
injury I don't know much about that but
I was sitting in front with a couple of
passengers we got the masks on and as
soon as we landed we were thankful the
pilots did a great job the crew did a
great job
they got us down to Philly and that's
when I took a photo of the engine and it
appeared that it shredded the left side
engine completely so we were coming down
we dropped 30,000 feet to 25 thousand
feet the pilot regained control it was
pretty scary the pilots did a great job
so who exactly is this woman Leslie say
she was one of the first female fighter
pilots and the first woman to fly in
f-18 she wasn't permitted to fly in
combat but she became an aggressive an
aggressor pilot and an instructor and of
course she is also a religious Christian
she talks about the fact that every time
she flies she sees it as proof of Christ
in her life so sounds like a pretty
amazing person and well worth
celebrating ok time for a quick thing
that I hate all righty time to give you
the update on the Starbucks the
Starbucks boycott the stupid Starbucks
boycott so as I say yesterday I said
yesterday on the show that I am
skeptical of the stories that some vast
swath of racism is happening across the
country by Starbucks employees and I
showed you a tape from one Starbucks and
torrents which is an area that is about
40% and the 35% Asian and I think it's
about 2% black and and largely Hispanic
as well so it's it's a heavily minority
area and this this Starbucks employee
supposed the Asian supposedly told the
black guy he couldn't use the restroom
and always saw of the tape is what the
black guy had to say about it but we
never heard the managers account of
exactly what happened but the same thing
happened at the Starbucks in
Philadelphia that led this whole thing
off but it turns out that the manager of
the Starbucks has spoken out her name is
Holly and she has spoken relatively
anonymously what she says happens is
that these two black guys come in and
they sit down and then they not only
refuse to leave but when asked politely
to leave because they're not buying
anything
begin to get a little bit aggressive
with her they begin to and she calls the
police like they just won't leave she
says then they come in they say can we
use the restroom she says no and then
they just sit down and they say there
now do I believe her do I believe the
two black guys who were talking about
this well you know all I can say is that
the supporting evidence tends to tends
toward the story of the of the manager
and the reason I say that is because the
police chief was a black guy said that
when the police came and they asked
these two guys to leave that you guys
said no the two guys refused they said
go ahead and arrest us you know they
were apparently relatively aggressive
with the officers as well not only that
but it turns out that this woman Holly
who was the who's the new store manager
I got a letter from one of these
listeners to the ben shapiro show who
routinely goes to this particular
starbucks and knows the manager and here
is what she wrote me when she wrote me
is i don't know what happened last week
with its two guys i wasn't there but i
highly doubt that she saw the two men
and decided to call the police based
solely on the fact that they are black
well according to this this person who
listen to the show quote from my
observations and interactions with her i
was actually under the impression that
holly is an sjw feminist of the highest
order
once i even heard her scorn a male
barista for not using the proper neutral
pronouns of somebody that's why this
whole situation is so shocking to me
even though i did not agree with her and
all the SJW pins that adorn her beanie i
think calling her a racist all over the
news in daxing her name address phone
family etc is disgusting the patron said
Holly's not racist and doesn't deserve
what is happening to her here in Philly
the patrons of the Starbucks are quote
bloke black and white and I've
personally seen Holly give the oh so
coveted restroom code to both black and
white people patrons and non patrons
I've seen her trained both black and
white staff members she's been nothing
but nice to everyone I've never
witnessed any racist behavior I mean I
agree with the way she carries herself
with the colorful hair and the hippie
pins but I can recognize when someone is
doing their job well again it would be
very weird if Holly were a giant racist
working in Philadelphia at a Starbucks
the city is 42 percent black it did that
they'll just be a very weird hiring
decision and she lasted a year at the
job without anybody else having any
complaints so I find this whole story
somewhat suspicious but Starbucks is a
soft target Starbucks is never going to
say that the incident didn't happen or
defend their employee they're always
going to cave in to the SJW Krab because
this is what they do this is the danger
of being on the side of the sjw's
eventually they always eat their own
okay so we'll be
tomorrow with all the latest I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing